[Music]  you're brought shame on our family  there's something unnatural your family  says you grapple with the demon if  there's a demon in me it's always been  [Music]  Tara no demons here Magdala she will do  God's will  [Music]  why shouldn't she following  people will judge us are we so different  from men you must teach us different  things  sometimes if I'm not here at all I'd  like to be one that's God no one has  ever asked me how it feels  the women are too afraid to be baptized  with the men gardener a man's he's not  right that he has raised you up to lead  us you love my son don't you you must  prepare yourself like me we need to take  him away from here whatever happens now  it's what God has asked of him you are  [Music]  I'll be with you to the end  we'll never speak again in his name the  world will only change as we change I  will not be silent  [Music]  I will be act  [Music]